[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAJEN SHETH: Hello, everyone.
Thank you all for joining.
We're going to talk a
lot about Chrome OS.
And what our strategy
is, particularly
for businesses and
for enterprise,
what we're doing with Chrome OS.
And so my name is
Rajen Sheth, and I'm
the director of product
management for Chrome
for business and education.
And we've been doing
a variety of things
over the course of
the last several years
with Chrome OS, particularly
oriented around education,
but now really starting to
focus a lot more on enterprise,
and we have some very,
very interesting places
where we think this is
applicable in enterprise.
So before we start off, I want
to kind of start with a story.
So February 22 was the
10-year anniversary
of G Suite, which
used to be called
Google Apps in the enterprise.
And I was the first
product manager for G Suite
and remember that
day quite well,
because we launched our first
kind of for-pay product out
of Google that was
not an Ads product.
And it was interesting to
think back to that time,
because one of the first
things that we did was we
went on a tour of
customers and we
talked to CIOs of a variety
of types about G Suite
and about the
cloud at that time.
And almost universally, we
were thrown out the door.
And I particularly remember
one customer where we went in,
five minutes into the meeting
they started to realize what
I was talking to them
about is taking their email
and moving it to our servers.
And so he clarified and said,
are you asking me really
to take my email and
move it to your servers?
And I said, yeah.
And he said, all right.
I think we're done here.
And so he gets up, leaves
the room, and that was it.
And it's amazing to see,
though, how that has changed
over that course of time.
Something that seemed crazy--
being able to put your
data in the cloud--
is now the mainstream.
It's why all of us are here.
What's interesting,
though, is that we really
think we're only
at the cusp of that
and there's much more
that can be done,
and so much else has also
changed, with mobility,
with devices.
You think about how we thought
about devices back then.
All of us probably
had one laptop
and that was all we used
for everything that we did.
Now the world has
changed dramatically,
and it gives us
many opportunities
to kind of rethink the world
and rethink what we do.
So the biggest opportunity
here is for businesses
to become data-centric.
And this is both a challenge
as well as an opportunity.
Almost every business
has data, of course.
And businesses have been
data-centric, to an extent,
for a long time.
But what really
changes right now
is how rapidly you can take
in the data, how rapidly you
can process that data, and how
rapidly you can do something
about it and actually change
your business as a result.
And so what we
want to help with,
with the combination of Chrome
devices and Android and Google
Cloud, is to really help
businesses become data-centric.
And what I mean by that is
kind of this flow right here.
This is our connected
workspaces virtuous cycle.
And where it all starts
is instrumenting.
First, as instrumenting
your business
with devices, with spaces,
with a variety of places,
such that you're
bringing data in.
The second thing is
drawing better insights
out of that data.
And then the third thing
is actually making changes
with it, either via people
actually looking at the data
and making those changes,
or via machines actually
making those changes
automatically in their stead.
And this is really the
opportunity that we have.
So imagine if every
organization out there
had all parts of its
business connected
to the cloud at all times.
And when I say "all
parts," I don't just
mean the knowledge workers
that you would typically
think of that are carrying
around smartphones
and computers.
I mean every worker.
And I don't mean
just every worker.
I mean all of their
customers as well--
people that might be
walking into a store, people
that they might be
interacting with.
And also, I don't just
mean the customers,
I mean all of the spaces.
So whether it's a retail store
or a manufacturing shop floor
or whatever it might be, what
if every thing there was also
connected to the cloud?
Imagine the kinds of
things that you can do.
I'll give you an
example of this.
So in a retail store, you think
about why we go to a store
right now.
You know, I buy a
lot of things online,
but the reason I
typically go to a store
is because I want to be able
to experience the product.
I want to be able to see it
and touch it and feel it.
I want to be able to browse
and find other things
that I might be interested in.
I might want to be able
to leverage the expertise
of the people in the store.
And then I want that
immediate gratification
of being able to say,
I want that item,
and then be able to just
walk out with it and buy it.
And so those are all great,
but the things that are missing
are all the things that you
get when you go online and buy.
When I go online and shop,
I can find something very,
very quickly.
I can find things that
are related to the things
that I like.
It knows me, and
so it knows what
I like and is able to actually
tell me more about it.
And then I can see
reviews about that item,
to see what other
people thought about it.
When I walk into
a physical store,
typically I don't
get any of that.
And so how do we make it
such that a space like that
is able to be better?
So for example, I should be
able to walk into a store
and have a screen
that greets me,
to be able to tell me where
in the store are things
that I'm interested in--
basically, based on either
something that I need to get,
or something that
I'm interested in.
When I find something, I should
be able to ask the store clerk,
and they should be knowledgeable
enough to tell me everything
that I need to know
about that item.
I should be able to see
more information about that,
in terms of reviews,
what other people think
about it, things like that.
And then I should be able
to purchase it right then
and there, as quickly and
seamlessly as possible,
and walk out.
That's the kind of experience
that really transforms that.
And we want to do that
from multiple industries.
So the reality of the world
is much, much different.
So first of all, there are
about 3.25 billion workers
that walk into a workplace
of one type or another
around the world right now.
But there are only 750 million
PCs in business right now,
and there are only
about 300 million
managed smartphones
out there right now.
And so there's a
large number of people
that when they are
in the workplace,
they are not connected
to the cloud.
They don't have devices.
They can't take advantage
of the kinds of things
that I just talked about.
And there are a
lot of spaces that
are also just not connected.
So how do we actually
make that a reality?
So we believe that with
Chrome OS and with Android,
we have the right tools to be
able to make that a reality.
So both Chrome OS
and Android were
developed in the age
of the connected world.
It was developed with
the internet pervasively
out there, with mobile
internet out there everywhere.
And as a result of
that, we built this
with the concept of connectivity
inherently built into it.
We've also built these
operating systems
to be extensible across many,
many, many different types
of devices, everything from
a very large digital sign,
all the way down to a
sensor or a sensor hub
or the internet of things,
and everything in between.
And so as a result
of that, we can now
start to actually
instrument and actually
get devices into many more
places and to many more people.
And if you look at just the
devices that go to people,
we have OEMs by the thousands
that are actually manufacturing
these kinds of devices.
And so we can really start to
address that gap of people that
don't have access to devices.
And with Chrome in
particular, we're
really focusing
on two big things
to try to make this better.
The first is to redefine
the concept of productivity,
and the second is the concept
of connected workspaces.
And so I'm going to go into
these in a lot more detail
and we're going to show
you some examples of what
we're talking about here.
So when we think
about productivity,
the way I would
think about this is
that we usually, in the past,
have thought about productivity
as a laptop and a set
of tools on that laptop
to let you be able
to create documents
or create presentations
or create spreadsheets,
things like that.
What we now need to really
think about is, if we zoom out,
what is productivity, really?
Especially if you have a device
in the hands of every employee
out there.
Productivity for, for
example, a field technician,
is going to be a very
different type of thing
than productivity for somebody
that's sitting in an office.
Productivity for a salesperson
is also a very different thing.
So how do we rethink of the
concept of productivity?
The other thing, though, is
that we're getting to a world
where mobility is in the
hands of almost everybody.
Almost everyone carries a
smartphone in their pocket.
And so part one is, how can we
enable those smartphones to do
great things for these workers?
But then part two of
that is then, how do we
enable devices that are bigger--
tablets, laptops,
and other things
that are connected to that
mobile environment, that
run the same applications,
that are continuous
from that environment, as
opposed to discontinuous
from that environment,
a completely
different environment?
And so that's what
we've been really
thinking about with Chrome OS.
How can Chrome OS be
the right productivity
device for the mobile world?
So one of the big challenges
that people typically face
is, which device should
you choose at what times?
A lot of times, people
don't have the luxury
of having all of these devices.
They may have one.
They may have two of these.
And you have to be
switching back and forth
between all of these.
What we're trying
to figure out is,
can we do it such that
you don't have to choose,
and you don't have to switch
back and forth between these,
and we can make the
device that can actually
be versatile enough to
be all of these things?
And then the second
thing is then,
how do we tie all of
these things together?
And so that's really what
we've thought about as we've
designed Chrome OS.
So the first thing we did is
we took a step back to say,
if we redefined the
PC, what would it be?
What would be the
characteristics of a PC
if we had to reinvent it?
And we came up with this list.
One, it should be fast.
You want to be able
to get in and get
to what you want to do as
quickly as you possibly can.
The second thing is
it should be easy.
So any user should be
able to start using it
without any training, and
be able to get in and do
what they want to do.
And that lets you scale to
users of many different types.
The third thing is that
it should be secure.
Security is obviously a
very, very difficult thing
with devices.
But especially if you want
to have more and more devices
out there, security
becomes really critical.
So how do we take the security
model and turn it on its head
and do interesting
things with it,
so that you ensure, just out
of the box and inherently,
people are secure
on their computers?
One other aspect that
was critical here,
that we didn't realize
would be this critical
when we first started this
project, but has been crucial
in a variety of areas,
is shareability.
With a Chromebook, I can pick
up any Chromebook, log in to it,
and within seconds, I
have everything I need.
I have all my data.
I have all my applications.
I have even all my preferences.
Even down to the wallpaper,
everything is the same.
And then I could put that
away, go to another one,
pick it up, and
do the same thing.
In a world where everybody
has their own PC,
that doesn't really
matter a whole lot.
But what we're seeing
is a shift there.
And especially in a world where
people want different devices
at different times, you may not
want to arm every single person
with all devices at all times.
You may want to have it
such that people can pick up
the right device
whenever they need it,
and be able to do what
they want with it.
One example of this is,
again, in retail stores.
We've seen this
happen quite a bit,
where they may have 50
sales associates that
may go through that retail
store on a given day,
but they may have
only room to be
able to do two or three devices.
But if they want to move all
of their processes online,
those 50 people
are going to have
to share those two or three
devices very, very well.
And Chrome has that
built in, inherently,
as one of its things.
A couple of last things is that
these devices should get better
over time.
Typically, when you buy a
device, or when you buy a PC,
over time it gets worse
and worse and worse
and more bloated and
slower, and eventually you
need to then just replace
it with something else.
We wanted to make it such
that these get actually
better over time, and
they don't get worse.
And the last thing is that
we want it to be versatile,
so that it should
be able to shift
between different
types of use cases,
and shift very naturally.
So on that last point
about versatility,
there are two parts of it.
One is kind of the
continuity with what people
are doing elsewhere, and
then the second thing
is the device itself.
So in terms of
continuity, we wanted
to ensure that the way
people are interacting
with their smartphone is
also how they can interact
with their PC, and
then they can start
interacting with it
in a different way
as well, when they need
kind of full productivity,
multiple windows,
multi-processing,
things like that.
And so there are a few areas
that we looked at with that.
The first is the device itself.
So the device--
originally, Chromebooks
have been laptop devices.
And what we've
now done is really
focused on making
them more versatile,
and making them
convertible devices,
and eventually, things like
detachable devices and tablets
and things like
that as well too.
So the examples you
see here are a couple
of the new devices we released--
the Samsung Chromebook
Pro and the ASUS
Chromebook Flip,
where you can flip
these devices over
and you're able to interact
with them like a tablet,
and actually interact with
them very well as a tablet.
A couple of small things that we
did to really make this great,
so the Samsung device
is a 3 by 2 ratio,
whereas most PC screens
are a 16 by 9 ratio.
And we did that because
we knew that when
you want to go into a
tablet mode, a 3 by 2 ratio
is actually a lot better.
If I want to flip it on its
side and look at it like a book
or like a piece of
paper, a 3 by 2 ratio
is the right thing to do.
So to that degree, we wanted
to make it a great tablet.
But then beyond that,
too, another thing
that we see is very important
is writing and stylus.
And so we built styluses
into many of these devices,
so you can now write
on this device.
So I can use this device,
in an average business day,
as my fully-productive
primary laptop.
I can use it as a
tablet, when I want
to flip through a presentation
or when I want to read a book
or when I want to read a
paper or whatever it might be.
And I can use it as my notebook
to take notes in a meeting.
And so you can use
it as all three
of these, kind of all at once.
But anybody can do that,
in terms of the hardware.
What really makes this
work well is the software.
And so if you think about
convertibles or detachables
of other types that
you see in the market,
there's a fundamental
problem you run into,
which is you may have a
convertible or detachable
that's a wonderful PC,
but then when you flip it
into tablet mode, you don't
have the applications there
to be able to make
it a great tablet.
Or you might have it such
that it has a great mobile app
ecosystem, but then when you
start to do productive things
and you want to have
multiple screens
and you want to have kind
of that multitasking,
it's not very good at that.
We need it to be good
at both, and so one
of the things we
introduced last year
is the idea of Android apps
running on Chromebooks.
And we're rolling that out
to all of the Chromebooks
that are being sold
in the market in 2017.
And now what you can
do is essentially
run the entire Google Play
Store on the Chromebook
and be able to leverage any of
the 2 million applications that
are there.
And so it gives you that kind
of flexibility and versatility
from an application perspective.
You still get the productivity
of a Chromebook-- you know,
multiple-sized window apps,
world-class desktop browser,
multitasking, access to desktop
virtualization for your Windows
apps, all of those
kinds of things,
and the manageability
that comes with it.
But then in addition
to that, you
get all of these
touch-optimized applications.
And you have that consistency.
So if you're using an
application on your smartphone,
you can also use that same
application on your laptop
now as well, too.
And so this is something
that lets us kind of then
really span from the
phone all the way
up through large device.
And the last part
of that is really
kind of the access to the
different types of apps
that you have.
And so now we support HTML5,
and we support Google Play.
But we've also done
interesting things
to integrate in Windows apps.
And so for example, we've
worked with folks like Citrix
to make it such that a
Windows app can actually
be launched from our launcher,
just like any other app.
So you'll see an icon for
that app in our launcher.
You click on that app and it
opens it in its own window.
If you didn't know
anything, you wouldn't even
know that that was actually
an app that wasn't resident
on that device.
And so that way, you
can go to even the apps
that you were using on other
platforms as well, too.
So that's kind of how we're
working on mobile productivity.
You're going to see many more
things that we're doing there.
But the other part
of this is this idea
of connected workspaces.
How do we take a space--
and like I was saying, a retail
store, a manufacturing shop
floor, a variety of
spaces, an office space--
and really make that
space connected,
and combine the power of Chrome
and Android with Google Cloud
to do really
interesting things, in
particular, vertical solutions?
And we think that
by doing this, we
can actually
transform these spaces
and actually create value.
So in the retail
store, make it such
that people end up selling more.
In a manufacturing
shop floor, make
it so it's a much more
efficient environment
as a result of this, and so take
a very verticalized approach
to this as well, too.
So we talked about this
a little bit before,
but if you look at how
people think of data insights
and actions right now
and how they should be,
it is a little bit different.
So data, we're in an
environment right now,
in many cases, where data
is either non-existent or is
based on poor sources
or is really incomplete.
And in addition to that, a
lot of the data coming in
might not be stored in
a centralized place.
So how do we get
it such that it's
gathered from many different
sources, from more sources,
and stored centrally?
The second part of
this is the insights
that you get from them are
oftentimes very subjective.
So how can you make it
such that you're actually
drawing useful
feedback from this data
and actually getting
the right insights?
And how do you get it such
that you're drawing insights
that a human may not have
found, if they're looking
at that same piece of data?
And then helping enterprises
and organizations by doing that.
The last part is
then the actions.
A lot of times actions
are very slow to roll out.
How can you make the actions,
in some cases, immediate, such
that the systems themselves
can learn from themselves
and get better and
better over time?
So we think that with the
combination of Android
and Chrome and Google
Cloud Platform and G Suite,
we can actually
start to do this,
because with Android
and Chrome, you
can start to get more devices
of many different types
out there to different
environments,
and as a result of that,
more data coming in with it.
You can also have a
great security model
by which you can actually
secure and manage
these devices in
a consistent way,
such that you're able to
increase the number of devices
without increasing the
number of IT people
that you need for that.
The second part is
Google Cloud Platform.
Using things like BigQuery
and machine learning,
you can start to draw insights
out of this immediately,
and start to draw those kinds
of insights, like I was saying,
that you may not see
with the human eye.
And then the last
part of this is
you can connect it to the
productivity tools like G
Suite, such that humans can
actually take a look at this
and be able to gather their
own insights out of this.
Finally, we can connect it to
a variety of other things going
on within Google that make
this story even better-- things
like Firebase, to make it
so that you can very quickly
and easily develop mobile
applications, things
like DoubleClick, such that you
can be able to push content out
to some of these
devices very easily,
especially things that are
in customer-oriented spaces,
things like progressive
web apps and Polymer that
make it easy to build very,
very solid applications
on the front end, and then
things like Google Assistant,
eventually, which can
make it so that users
can start to get insights
from this as well, too.
And so if we look at
that virtuous cycle
that I talked about
at the beginning,
you can start by instrumenting
things with the devices
that we talked about.
You can then analyze them
with the tools of Google Cloud
Platform.
And then you can improve
them using that data
and using apps built
on top of that that can
change automatically with this.
And we offer many of
the parts that are here.
But then the other
part is that this
offers an opportunity
for partners
to be able to actually build
on top of this as well,
and build things
that are specific
for particular verticals.
And you're going to hear
about one of these solutions
in a little bit, where it opens
up a set of APIs by which you
can do this and actually
connect together
all of the various applications
that are there within Google.
So let me give you
an example of this.
All of us have
gone into a store,
and when we first
go into a store,
we see a bunch of
different signs
that are there with the store.
Many of these signs are paper.
We've now gotten to the
point where with Chrome, we
can make it as inexpensive to
put up a digital sign as it
is to put up a paper sign, and
in some cases, less expensive,
because the paper sign you have
to keep changing over time.
A digital sign, you
don't have to do that.
One of the things we have, we
released a couple years ago,
was an $85 dongle called
the Chromebit, which
you can stick into a monitor
and turn that monitor
into a smartscreen, basically
turn any screen that you
have into a digital sign.
So we're now starting
to see retailers
start to use it in
really interesting ways
to have up-to-date
information on their sign.
We're starting to
see, though, others
use this in a very
interesting way
to be able to do
even more than that
and actually gather
insights from that sign
and be able to actually
change things as they go on.
And so I'm going
to play this video.
This is from Coca-Cola.
Coca-Cola has been doing some
phenomenal things with Chrome
to be able to really generate
more sales in grocery
stores of Coke products
and other products
with digital signs.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --that they had,
all over the world,
in every corner of the globe.
It's an amazing thrill to be
able to work on it, really,
with the world's most respected
brand, as closely as I
get to shape the future of it.
One of the things that
we see with the emergence
of e-commerce is this change
in consumer demand, this idea
that we want
environments-- and store
environments, especially-- to be
more dynamic, more responsive,
and more personalized.
How do I create an
environment that you walk in
and you have instant wow factor?
How do I make it easy
for brands to be able
to [INAUDIBLE] the latest and
greatest content, the latest
and greatest experiences,
to store shelves and store
aisles nationwide instantly?
And we do that with some
really intelligent technology,
and that's part of why we like
partnering with Google so much.
We start assembling things
within the marketplace- things
like DoubleClick, things
like Google's Nearby API,
their Proximity API.
And once we figured out
that we could use the cloud
to interconnect all these
amazing products together,
we were able to put together,
with a Chromebit, Chrome OS,
DoubleClick, and a
little bit of magic
from the cloud, an endcap that
had a beautiful screen that we
were able to [INAUDIBLE] in real
time, targeted digital content.
Ultimately, the endcap
was able to produce for us
an incredible ROI, and do it
at 10% of the cost of what's
in the marketplace today.
- Coke really is
at the leading edge
of trying to figure
out how to use devices
in the cloud in
very strategic ways.
This idea of taking a
store and connecting it
really is what we're
all about, and we're
focusing a lot of our attention
on making that happen.
- These new digital
tools allow us
to bring the Willy Wonka to
life, to bring the magic back,
to bring things back to the
retail environment that wow,
amaze, surprise, and
delight every single one
of our loyal consumers.
And Coke and Google will
be right there every step
of the way.
[END PLAYBACK]
RAJEN SHETH: So one of the
amazing things about that
is that they found that by
putting this endcap there,
their cost of doing
that repays itself
within less than a month,
which is just extraordinary,
and that is through uplift
of sales as a result of that.
They're also able to use things
like the Google Nearby API
to be able to
gather demographics
of who might be near the sign
and who might be interacting
with the sign.
So for example, they
can put an offer up
on the sign that
can be broadcast
via the Chromebox, which can
turn itself into a beacon
and broadcast a URL
out, and then that
can be actually
retrieved and used
by a customer that happens
to be going past that sign.
And that makes the sign
interactive as well, too,
so they can better figure
out what kinds of things
works, what kinds of
things don't, and be
able to dynamically
change their business.
And this is a great
example of what
we're talking about with this
idea of connected workspaces
that iterate upon themselves.
So in the concept of
the store of the future,
there are many
opportunities like this.
One is to empower employees.
I was mentioning with
a lot of retail stores
that want to be able to actually
bring more of their employees
online and actually put more
of their processes online.
You can now bring Android
devices and Chromebooks
into those stores in
a shared manner, such
that you can empower
those employees.
You can do things like training.
You can do things
like shift scheduling.
You can do a variety of
other things like that
and be able to empower
those employees.
This concept of
augmented shopping,
you want to be able to
actually help somebody
when they're shopping.
So for example, a mirror
that might show you
what you would look like with
a particular type of clothing
on it, or be able to
transmit an offer to you.
Immersive experiences, using
things like virtual reality
to be able to actually,
for example, take a sofa
and see what it might look like
in your house before you go
and buy it.
And then on the back-end, being
able to kind of streamline
the services-- streamline
checkout, streamline
management, streamline the
supply chain as well by giving
better data into
the system to be
able to know what a different
store or a particular store
really needs.
Another great example of
this is manufacturing.
How can you actually put
these kinds of devices
onto a shop floor, for
example, to actually make
those factory floors more
efficient and better?
And this could be
through smarter systems.
It could be through connecting
the sales people directly
to those systems and making
the supply chain better.
So great example of
this has been Sanmina.
And so Sanmina has
been a customer
that has been using G Suite
and Chrome for a very long time
and has really figured out the
impact of how this can really
help their business.
So I'm going to turn it over
to Srinivats Ramaswamy, who's
going to tell you a
little bit about what
Sanmina has been doing.
SRINIVATS RAMASWAMY:
Thank you, Rajen.
Good afternoon, all.
Let me start with just a
quick introduction of myself
before we get into
the actual content.
I'm Srinivats Ramaswamy.
I'm a vice president
of IT at Sanmina.
Also I am the CTO for 42Q.
I'll touch upon the connectivity
of the two organizations
in a few minutes.
What we did, as
Rajen pointed out
through the discussion
or the presentation,
was how did we streamline
our manufacturing processes?
What did we do in enabling
collaboration, connecting
front office and
back office using
Chrome devices and the cloud
to enable our people to be
more effective?
That's kind of the theme of
my content going forward.
So before I get in here, just a
quick question to the audience.
How many of you guys
are in manufacturing?
Just if you could raise
your hands, just to kind of
understand the context.
OK.
All right.
So it's a small audience
there from that point of view.
All right.
So, very quickly,
Rajen started out,
he said a story
at the beginning.
You know, 10 years
ago, he said he
started with G Suite coming out,
and it's the 10th anniversary.
Let me tell you a story on
same thing on 42Q and Sanmina.
42Q is actually a--
we consider ourselves a leading,
cloud-based MES/MOM solution
provider.
So since the audience has
manufacturing familiarity, let
me give you-- if you go
to a factory anywhere,
you can see there's
a bunch of people,
a bunch of products flowing.
There's a lot of data
being tracked by people
on piece of paper, everything.
That industry generally
is called a manufacturing
execution area.
And the systems enable you
to basically automate that.
So 42Q is a leading
provider, and if you
think about 10 years
ago, G Suite came,
and that's been
[INAUDIBLE] prominent.
42Q was launched in
May of 2016, officially
to the public market.
And in that, Gartner
wrote an article
about us stating the first
pure-play cloud manufacturing
solutions provider.
So manufacturing is the
industry that's adopting cloud,
at last in general basis.
So that's our unique
differentiation.
42Q is also a business
unit of Sanmina.
I'm sure many of you haven't
heard about Sanmina, so
let me give you a quick view.
If you ever bought
a data center--
if you worked on the IT industry
and you bought a data center
equipment, like a rack--
chances are some part of that
rack came out of Sanmina.
We make servers, switches,
routers for OEMs,
cables, whatever
the case might be.
Sanmina is also a
large corporation
with [INAUDIBLE] globally.
So we also have our
communications sector,
medical devices.
If you go into a hospital,
had an MRI or an ultrasound,
chances are some parts
of it came from us.
We build on behalf of companies
in the medical sector.
The significance is that, as he
started earlier, what happened
for us was about five
years ago, when we started
to see our industry as
very volatile, a few of us
got together and
said, we need to get
to the cloud to enable our
businesses to operate better.
And so that's when we had
the idea that, let's put
this thing in the cloud.
So we brought in a few people.
Ironically, we had a similar
experience that Rajen said.
The feedback I got
from consultants,
from multiple employees,
was, are you serious?
There is so much
happening on the floor.
There's no way you can move
this thing to the cloud.
So we formed a small team.
We kind of looked at what we do.
We migrated our application.
This application has been
built over 15 to 20 years
within Sanmina for
our own manufacturing.
We had it rewritten
for the cloud,
and we did a prove
point, and then
we realized that this thing
is starting to work for us.
And as we start to migrate
out, our customers asked,
and that led to the formation
of 42Q in 2013 internally.
And then we did the go-to-market
activities and we launched.
The thing that's interesting
as you go through
is, in order to enable people
to operate in the cloud,
you need a gateway.
And that's where, I think,
the role of Chrome and Android
significantly propelled us
to get to the cloud segment.
So moving forward,
how does this work?
So you're buying product
from your customer.
You expect the product,
when they come to you,
to be very well designed, very
well tested, and completely
fully functional.
Every customer of 42Q
expects the same thing.
So today, in the
cloud platform, we
are getting over hundreds
of millions of widgets going
through our platform today.
Right, and that's the kind
of volume we are handling.
And when you think about
that, when people are building
a product in that kind
of volume and complexity,
what's important
is the production
supervisors want to make sure
that they are supplementing
the operator capability
and the machine capability
with automation that
will prevent mistakes.
Right, simple example would be
if you're building a product
and the testing shows you
that the product's kind
of going to the tolerance
level, when you're out of it,
it will automatically
stop the machine.
So we do things like that,
what we call a forced quality
framework, that allows
production supervisor to really
manage the factory.
So what are the key
questions they ask?
Did I build the product
correct the first time?
It's a simple question, but when
you look below that, what does
"did they build it
correctly?" mean?
Did the correct people touch it?
So we have to track
every operator.
So our Chrome and
Android devices
where the operator
interacts with,
we track the transactions.
Who did it?
What happened?
When?
The timestamping is
extremely critical.
Right, so if you're building
an FDA class 3-- class 3,
for people who don't know, is
it's intrusive into your body
and people could die if
it's produced incorrectly.
So when you're building
a product like that,
timestamping and traceability
becomes so critical,
and that's why we call it
the forced quality framework.
Really, it ensures
that the right people
touched the product.
The machines were calibrated
and maintained correctly.
The quality data was collected
and processed correctly
so that the product
can be shipped.
And lastly, we make sure that
with all of that information,
there was management
oversight and approval
to deliver the quality product.
So that's really our
forced quality framework
that allows our customers
to effectively use it.
And with all of this
happening in the cloud,
the gateway is generally a
Chrome device or an Android
device.
So let's talk about the
devices assets used.
Typically, in a
factory floor, when
somebody is building
a product, what
happens is that, as
Rajen mentioned earlier,
sales are sitting in the
front office taking orders.
And invariably, it
happens that there will
be a really critical order.
Somebody wants to
follow through.
You want to make sure you're
getting the right data.
You want to make sure
that you are effectively
delivering the product
to what you promised.
And what happens in our
world is you can actually
use a Chromebook or
an Android tablet,
log in to the
application as a sales,
export the data into G Suite,
share it with your production
supervisor, and say, here
is kind of the five things
that I want to do.
Get me back in this so
I can share the more
recent learnings
to the customer,
or whatever the case might be.
So what you're really doing is,
historically, what people do,
they'll take a piece of
paper, walk over, take notes
on what needs to be
captured, come back in,
craft the email out.
What you have done now, with
this kind of an environment,
is that you've changed
the whole thing.
First and foremost, you allowed
them to get access to data.
Second is you allowed
them to take it
to a collaborative
environment like G Suite that
allows you to share
with the front office
and effectively communicate.
And that's really
the one part of that.
The second piece
is, as I mentioned,
factories have machines.
The machines is an
interesting part.
If you think about where
the world is going,
the common theme
is industrial IOT.
And everybody has heard
about industrial IOT,
but I can tell you, industrial
IOT for manufacturing
is progressing slowly.
Part of the reason why
it's progressing slowly
is the complexity.
You heard about the
capabilities we deliver.
Imagine, typically, in
an on-premise solution,
when somebody buys
something like that,
they're going to buy
roughly about anywhere
from six to eight
servers, minimum, and up.
You got to get them set up.
You've got to configure them.
You've got to get
them up and running.
You got to install the
application, train the people.
You don't need to do all
of that with the cloud.
Similarly, when
machine connectivity,
our view of the
world was, how do you
make that complexity go away?
How do you simplify
industrial IOT?
So what we enable is there's two
kinds of models you can have--
machines that can talk to
cloud, the newer machines
are cloud-friendly.
Great.
You can use a standard
protocol, IOT protocol
and connect to us like MQTT.
Or you can use a Chrome
that can be on site, right,
but it's still
local software-less.
It's one environment
for everybody.
It connects, talks to the cloud,
and assures you the local data
integrity.
So that's how we
connect the machines
and enable IOT for
the open market.
Lastly, you know, if you
think about the products
that we build,
products can be as
small as what we're
carrying in the hand,
to some products that are
built by our customers that
are really huge.
They could be 16 feet
long, eight feet tall,
and a really broad
equipment, size of a room.
So you had to build a
solution that allows you
to be able to balance the two.
And so our Android
platform basically
allows you to have a really
significant user interface
that you can read from 10
feet, 12 feet, or 15 feet
away, for operators
who are operating
with really bulky products.
It's a really tailored platform,
but uses the same framework.
Everything's running
on the cloud,
provides you with the ability
to communicate and collaborate
with our back-end solution.
If you've been to
a factory, you know
digital signage has changed
the world of a factory.
You're smiling.
Is that a question?
No?
All right.
Digital signage has changed
the world of the factory,
because in the old
days, people used
to put charts of quality
information in the factory.
When you walk in,
you can see it.
You'll see the Lean and the Six
Sigma and all the terms there.
All that's gone away, and now
you have a digital signage
solution.
What's powerful about this?
In the old days, you
could have a signage
only inside the factory.
With today's world, with our
solution running on the cloud,
and with the Android
equipment that you
can use for displaying
anywhere, we're
able to enable digital signage.
I could have a
corporate office here
that has a signage
of my factory,
as in this case, the
factories in Singapore.
Not only that, this
signage actually,
as he pointed out in the case of
the Coca-Cola, similarly here,
our IOT platform enables you
to get real-time information
of the machines, and
it shows you in red,
green, yellow in
an easy visual form
as to whether there's a problem.
It also shows you,
if there's a problem,
has somebody responded to it?
And if you're an
executive traveling,
you can get that on
your mobile device.
Foundationally, all
of this is enabled
by using one consistent
platform to deliver the content.
The last use case I
want to leave you with
is general operations
management.
Now, we talked about,
if you think about where
the world's going,
is cloud's become--
from the start of the cloud,
we started with burst capacity,
and now it's mainstream.
Same thing for manufacturing.
It's becoming mainstream.
We don't need any more
hardware, software,
anything to be run on premise
to get manufacturing connected.
You can connect the front
office to the back office
now with real-time
transparency so people
are able to collaborate
and effectively respond
to their customer demands.
You're also able to easily
connect the factory machines
to the back end.
With the kind of volume
that's going through today
in this platform, we
get data from machines,
we get data from over
hundreds of millions
of widgets that goes
out, effectively
through our product.
And all of this is
able to do it today
because we don't have
to deal with putting
an application that runs
a software on premise
and doing a lot of things.
And we use, basically, our
Android and Chrome platforms
to be able to be literally
software-less on premise,
and that's the power
of the devices that
allows us to fundamentally
simplify and even
enable industrial
IOT for manufacturing
for a vast majority
of our customers.
Rajen?
RAJEN SHETH: Thank you,
and I think it really
kind of embodies
how you can really
change an environment
when you add the devices
and we add Cloud into this.
So there's an estimate
that if we think about-- we
talked about 10 years back.
If we think about
10 years from now,
there's an estimate
that 10 years from now,
there will be 100
billion devices
connected to the internet, which
is just a staggering number.
I mean, that will basically
be 10 to 15 devices
per human being on this planet
connected to the internet.
And if you think about that, it
seems unbelievable right now.
But just like the
cloud was unbelievable,
just like those concepts were
unbelievable 10 years ago,
that is kind of
where we're heading.
But the point there really isn't
about the number of devices.
Really, it's about
the value that you
can create by doing
that and actually
putting more devices out there.
By collecting more
data, by being
able to evaluate that data, you
can create empowered employees.
You can create
engaged customers.
And you can create
intelligent spaces.
So with that, we'd be happy
to take any questions.
There's a microphone
in the center,
and we have a roving
mic as well, too.
Anyone?
OK, well, if there are
any questions afterwards,
please feel free
to come up to us
and we'd be happy
to talk to you more.
All right.
Thanks a lot.
We appreciated your time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]